i do believe that this country was
founded on certain principles and i
believe
we believe in the second amendment we
are proposing
um armed self-defense on position as it
relates to
the situation with black people here in
america
dealing with police departments one of
the great untold stories about the civil
rights movement was that it
it required violent resistance from
blacks to be effective
the huey p newton gun club gained
national attention in the wake of the
michael brown shooting and the
subsequent
ferguson riots but club president
charles goodson
says that he and a small group of
activists actually
founded the club in the summer of 2014
after learning that dallas police have
shot at 40 unarmed suspects
according to their own records we
attended a meeting of the gun club which
takes its name
from black panther party co-founder huey
p newton
and we talked with historian thaddeus
russell about the long
intertwined history of the gun rights
and civil rights movements
the fact that we use the gun is just a
political tool
as much as it is a provocative thing i
think in these days and age when you
have
black men and black women etc and 12
year old child
being shot down i think we're living in
profane times the gun is a tool
it's a tool for the oppressed masses to
rise up and throw off the tyranny
self-defense is a human right
you have your rights your second
amendment rights if we are citizens in
this country
then that applies to african-americans
as well black americans have been using
guns ever since they were black
americans
during slavery there were some armed
revolts in which slaves
stole guns or simply used ones that were
given to them it really began as a
movement after slavery after the civil
war during reconstruction
when the ex-slaves were left to fend for
themselves in the south and against a
rising hostile opposition
to them by organizations like the ku
klux klan who were formed during that
period
largely as an attempt to suppress the
slaves and stop them from gaining
political rights and civil rights and
their freedom
the klan at the time was really the
first
gun control organization in american
history that was one of their primary
missions was to disarm the ex-slaves
instead of being lynched in alabama or
being lynched in mississippi somewhere
we're being lynched now in st louis
we're being lynched
on live stream video with eric gardner
will being
lynched on camera with oscar grant and
so
we call ourselves uap news because of
the the the platform that they took
as it relates to the police there's no
question that huey p newton bobby seal
and the black panther party
launched the modern gun rights movement
we give credit to the nra
usually but that's not the case in
california in the 1960s it was
essentially an open carry state
at that time very loose gun laws and the
black panthers took advantage of that at
one point
they marched on the state capitol with
guns
black men with rifles marched into the
state capitol building in sacramento in
response to that
bill was passed which became the
california's first gun control law which
eventually became the model for a
national gun control law
so the panthers really were the first
gun rights movement
and the response to them which was by
the way a republican
response authored by a republican
congressman and ronald reagan who was
governor at the time
was the first gun control anti-movement
when they brought
all the military hardware back from
afghanistan and iraq who the hell do you
think they bring that back for
at the end of the day we already know
that the wrong terrorism
the first line of government is is your
local government
but the police is going to be the first
person you're going to come in contact
with that's that that represents
the uh the state whether i'm protecting
myself from a robber
a rapist or anyone that's trying to
brutalize and murder me we don't
differentiate when we say self-defense
one of the great untold stories about
the civil rights movement was that it
it required violent resistance from
blacks
to be effective the dogs and the fire
hoses were not used primarily against
the
the peaceful school children who were
marching thousands of people
showed up to watch this non-violent
protest
people who were not organized by king or
the sclc
and those people many of them threw
bricks and rocks
and bottles at the cops who were there
there were shots fired
several of bill connor's police officers
were wounded
this is all before he uses the hoses and
the dogs and in fact he used the dogs
and the hoses against those people now
if that hadn't happened right king would
have had very little leverage
to go to the the city elders with but
that's what he did in his letter from
birmingham jail he said
to the white leadership of birmingham he
said you have a choice you can deal with
those people in the streets
um and and have a an ocean of blood at
your hands
or you can deal with people like me you
know good peaceful
christian relatively law-abiding
citizens i'm not promoting violent
resistance
but there's no question that it has been
effective historically
no huey p newton gun club member will
accept grants
or money from the government we don't
want it
we don't want nothing from you anything
a person gives you to expect something
back
one of the things about accepting
government grants is that we feel that
we should do for ourselves but one of
the main reasons why we say that is
because
we feel that as long as we control it
then no one else can control it you
can't buy us
believe it or not we've found supporters
from all over the political spectrum
from the left from the liberal types
to the more conservative types and so
we've gotten a lot of response from the
conservative
people and you know national rifle
associations in groups like that
we don't consider ourselves to the far
right or to the far left we think
what we're doing is right on time you
know right now we're seeing in this
country we're seeing a
very interesting moment when um
categories of right and left are being
blurred and you see
sort of people on the far left joining
forces with people sort of on the
libertarian right
modern liberals are mostly interested in
social order
social control responsibility they're
not of the left in that sense right
they're not a revolutionary force
they're a managerial force and i think
that's why
they have been so eager to portray gun
rights as a right-wing
disruptive racist cause right which is
just simply not the case
what we want to leave with our people
and with the united states of american
citizens alike is that we desire to be
free
we desire to be able to practice several
termination and
we will continue to do so in so long as
we're
so long as we can move forward
you